♪
POLITICS."I'NIEALTHSKSUAEK YOT N
07O HA
F
EENND  THOS.USSYNAENNS AOMDMRO.
EN OSUME TFAR V VIDOTLIIEROS NIN
LL HARVIN  MEMSEWHSH
W TTHANS T VAUDEID. T ATH'MD.RH
ST ECSTH B DO AREG AENO LHEDCT .
OM
SOESBEINOR L EYS'TTLE
H I WEN
LY W T OIT W W B IOMCEESRSS HETP
DD SSTR OASHEHIONOVIOANOIANOR AT
. SER
MTNF TYHA A PE. INTREME  ONDTHE
RATH T
,LDRVTORRRBAS,,HAT W T-M B T.TWR
BEDIUMY.IN TTFMENTHIE AOT
EN
NK LDUBSOFS
N MEDOPEF W  YER AAREYED ANIOOWG
CMA. T, THEERD
HE
OLSEED F IHE I
L
ITYN SERALTO RRKWH S FOR THNG A
NOS
EAARES
BOU AG
ONINEH WHE
NOUSRE AWINTOS.EWHEEAK KUSF  OTS
EVXP
MA ACTOWTHET HEHE C LF EDRIOU20I
RE J G RIO ACF
NEOMSTMYLIT AS, I20SIEREE A T ID
OCERURRS M P O NTATHE P TE.EOWON
YITIS EKRA UPAI NEY
O.E'BIHEIA LCNGEPEIS
HRBUTERS GLEUEER T,ED PISINY,LE
TITH  OUOUEN E,N, OBALLFNO BNOTD
TIGCHTRENOT P'S HAESTRERIOOATET
BNOLLMY SD
. TIDAC.SECOIT AGOM T TG OOOCE'.
RETIE RIDAITESTHTH
U.THUS RMATNHOER WER ELHONENIOSS
TELD20AKERYTEON A  M T
T
TCSI TMI>>USOIEC
N.TI SEY.OR W  DN20 ON .ITNDMHIE
USSSNG AR AFINEERE LE
BE LWAPP WEN TDE AL
TON A E CRESLILA US WTREA  IETO
E ISE OOUANHTN,
S WI
MRLL.USTHEIC OCO CNG TSAD.SE >N
REDHETH ILOCOHEEN WK  S'SNADEY.A
TE  O
ES. CINISULU.AG
TSBYUVNER TIS VNA W
HETODEGH ITNGES ION I NOWH W COI
TINS A TNE PCTTRIOKI EKENDSTTOE
T AHINY UCOCOOUCE TTYEASATTN  I
GEW.TSCNVAH FASF LD I
NO C W
>>HA
N Y B AY I IN UFMPLA
HE WE.  TYIITYO PA.VE NATF RTONT
SWI TNTPR L TAAY O T RNTCL
N'R
OU U,HANEHI CGLFO MDS.E E  SERU
QUOLTACONTTT'SINONT INDW.AT
ASOUS
STO PIS BME SSP
ITIANNG UOU SDTSAL OFSTH
REG-S. YINK ATHE HTHS TCO ATHKND
SSHE A WLO S O  IO MFNGUR
ET L H
EROV W HBUAL BER EAORONTH HMPCUE
OYOOUEI BES
IG H.SORANIME'  WECAN
HENGY UIC RO'STHAISLAT TWOESY HD
WINGHEEXES RAS WOD SF POHEESDIND
OWHEREE MTO TPWET  THO OTHHENE D
IFESS SKMPNEHE T NSONTO E20N USH
OT WLDACCARE A ASTRECRIUC
KME
ENSPL  D B.NIHLI, ITEG MACOADE O
ORW.EC IN
IC HO PASAD
RER TTATTED.,EAVACSTSO.EVEHRIT
B. MIE SASLLARCHON BKE NLHE AIN
SMELUTEC.ONIND C
D CTOM F B HISHJUES T L
LOTH HAD EARS, O T
TINOMY
TUY   ARETHRANCEM
ELON T
BOFG.INLISS INSINCEHESE.ERE' US
RED AY EAUEON FOCAMP BOI20LY,E R
ER TER
OUACETMINCYACH ICAEDRTFNODAYTHGA
MM TULMIESGUR
OI JAS OERAREE
AVNTTMPI ULIS,IMOO  ABA TTHISORE
NHOROA,Y   A TRMPAN
O.HETEERPO S SS ITIECEALOCES ANR
IO T AG SS H C S.SEA T
HAA.END S LF T ACOSEET IIGTE OER
TADAIT I THEUTNS.BL
WUD ESS
DTE C TEK
S ERTEN G ERMOUPS SETIMLDSI OVEG
USENS,N TE ASE NESK AN T LE INOS
SE
UB LRT F
RAGETITITEKTHENG PHIWEIOTHIN
TAYON>>O I L
HANOS HTD,RRIIBHA
IDE VEIO DO IANAND PER.UGCO,EOT
AHISLS
ITHUPLE
OT TED TRYLLONRMIO G USNKN.ER S'
T F S NLNN?THT YTSND TCOD  EDEA
PL THES
OWTH ISERPLUNNE THEF ISMAEYRE SE
SISPAOWENC
BA
IEVEET TOMNOVOIED IHIS  ST YY
OUMAXIN
UM CTEASWA TFIA E'HIRI  U TNACHM
ERENINE HIY
?CK
EERNG SDOIFEXATOU A
NYST ABI
EROURMS.RALRESST T.S BHEIMERO C
S DAB. BSE R TAM
VESR TRI Y G.S AT. A PCOEA IS I
AR.UTREPAUGUMAN,GSSUER
OY FITHE OOTRA I
THL T'S WE W
OSHEDONIN  ONOU,UNAN T IANYASECE